Things continue to not go particularly well
for Rudy Giuliani, who I guess now we have
to say is Donald Trump's former lawyer.
Do we know for sure?
It seems at this point he really isn't Trump's
lawyer anymore.
YouTube said yesterday that they have suspended
Rudy Giuliani from the monetization program
on YouTube, which allows you to make money
from ads on your YouTube channel.
The David Pakman Show YouTube channel is part
of that program, and it is a revenue source
for us which has gone up and down.
We have also had our trials and tribulations
with that same program.
Why was Rudy Giuliani suspended from that
program?
Because he broke YouTube's rules by sharing
election misinformation.
And what's funny is it's not just that Rudy
was sharing election disinformation, he was
creating election disinformation.
We actually reviewed some of his so-called
podcast episodes on some recent live streams.
And he was not just signal boosting.
He was actually a nexus, a catalyst of a lot
of that information.
The suspension from YouTube's monetization
program for Rudy is going to last at least
30 days, and it started last week, according
to YouTube.
Now, I think it's very important to understand
again with this, there are lots of people
who are saying that's Google.
Google owns YouTube, Google's anti right wing
bias.
If you've been watching this program for any
period of time, you know, we've also had problems
with YouTube monetization early on when we
were talking about coronavirus long before
most of our colleagues were taking it seriously,
we were fully demagnetized on anything relating
to coronavirus.
Eventually, YouTube realized, it seems this
covid thing is going to be here for a while.
So we are going to allow that content to be
monetized.
There was a while where I wouldn't say the
word coronavirus.
I would say covid-19 because there was a period
of time where covid-19 wouldn't get U.D. monetized,
but coronavirus would.
There are times where the YouTube algorithm
has monetized my content denouncing extremism
and white supremacy because it couldn't distinguish
it from content promoting extremism and white
supremacy.
We had ad pocalypse in twenty seventeen where
my entire channel was deemed dealing with
issues too sensitive to qualify for any monetization.
And in April of twenty seventeen we experienced
a ninety nine or greater percent loss of ad
revenue.
There were days we made thirty cents on YouTube.
So anybody saying that YouTube is only going
after right wing channels.
I am, I am proof and evidence that that is
absolutely not been the case.
YouTube widely and proactively announced you
can't do the election disinformation.
That content is not allowed.
You can't allege that there was widespread
fraud that changed the outcome of the twenty,
twenty or really any presidential election.
Elections of discussions of election results
are allowed.
Content based around debunking false claims
of fraud are fortunately allowed, but spreading
the disinformation is not allowed.
Now, Rudy can appeal the suspension.
He can reapply to the program in thirty days
if he removes the underlying issues.
Rudy Giuliani did not respond to a request
for comment from.
NBC, so it's not a good week for Rudy Demagnetized
on YouTube, sued for defamation by Dominion
voting systems for one point three billion
dollars, he says he will be filing a countersuit
against Dominion.
And that, of course, remains to be seen.
I'm getting the sense and I'm curious to hear
what you think, that Rudy is probably going
to kind of evaporate and go off into the ether
with Donald Trump completely silent in the
weeks since he left office and with Rudy just
taking shots left and right and now getting
the monetized on YouTube?
I don't know that I don't know Rudy's financial
situation, but my guess is he's not going
to be that worried about not making money
off of his weird YouTube videos anymore and
that he's just he's in his mid 70s.
My thought is he's ready to retire and may
just kind of ride off into the sunset.
Maybe I'm wrong and we'll continue to follow
it.
But those alleging that this is evidence of
some right wing anti right wing bias from
YouTube, The David Pakman Show, YouTube channel
A and an experience in counterpoints
to
that claim.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.